500 FINISHED AHEAD 2 2-67B89
THE NASDAQ JUMPED 50 TODAY.
CONGRESSIONAL REPUBLICANS
ARE TRYING TO PUSH THROUGH
SOME BIG CHANGES TO THE
FINANCIAL REGULATIONS PASSED
AFTER THE ECONOMIC CRISIS OF
2008.
TONIGHT, CHIEF CONGRESSIONAL
CORRESPONDENT MIKE EMANUEL
TELLS US LAWMAKERS IN THE
ASTRONAUT AND THE HOUSE
SETRONAUT AND THE HOUSE
SENAONAUT AND THE HOUSE
SENATEAUT AND THE HOUSE
SENATE AT AND THE HOUSE
SENATE ANDAND THE HOUSE
SENATE AND TD THE HOUSE
SENATE AND THETHE HOUSE
SENATE AND THE HE HOUSE
SENATE AND THE HOUHOUSE
SENATE AND THE HOUSEUSE
SENATE AND THE HOUSE AE
SENATE AND THE HOUSE ARE
STILL WRANGLING OVER WHOSE
VERSION IS BEST.
>> EAGER TO ROLL BACK DODD
FRANK BANKING REGULATIONS
BUT KEY HOUSE MEMBERS WANT
TO GO FURTHER THAN THE
SENATE BILL.
IT'S CLEAR HOUSE SPEAKER
PAUL RYAN SEES IT AS AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THE
AGENDAS.
>> EVEN WITH THE SENATE AS
SLOW AS THEY ARE, WE ARE
GOING TO BE REPEALING AND
REPLACING DODD FRANK.
WE ARE ACTUALLY GETTING A
GREAT DEAL DONE FOR THE
COUNTRY.
>> LAST WEEK WHITE HOUSE
BUDGET DIRECTOR MICK
MULVANEY TOLD HOUSE MEMBERS
HE WOULD LIKE THE SENATE
BILL TO INCLUDE MORE OF
THEIR IDEAS.
>> TO THE EXTENT THAT Y'ALL
HAVE DONE REALLY GOOD WORK
TO FIND WAYS ON A BIPARTISAN
BASIS TO IMPROVE DODD-FRANK
GOD BLESS YOU.
LET'S SEE IF WE CAN'T ADD
THAT TO THE SENATE BILL.
IF NOT, SENATE BILL IS A
GREAT FALL-BACK.
IF IT CAN GET BETTER, WHY
WOULDN'T WE ACCEPT THAT AS A
REALLY GOOD OUTCOME.
>> 16 DEMOCRATS VOTED FOR
THE LEGISLATION IN THE
SENATE.
INCLUDING SOME FACING WHAT
ARE EXPECTED TO BE TOUGH
RE-ELECTION CAMPAIGNS AND
WHO ARE CO-SPAWN SORES OF
THIS BILL.
DONNELLY IN INDIANA.
HEITCAMP, NORTH DAKOTA.
MANCHIN WEST VIRGINIA.
McCaskill, Missouri, and
tester Montana.
THERE IS A POLITICAL
CALCULATION HERE BECAUSE
THOSE DEMOCRATS ARE UNDER
INTENSE PRESSURE FROM OHIO
SENATOR SHERROD BROWN AND
MASSACHUSETTS SENATOR
ELIZABETH WARREN AND THEIR
ALLIES.
FROM
>>OM
>> THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
NOT GOING TO STAND BY WHILE
BIG BANKS AND OTHER GIANT
CORPORATIONS RUN THIS
ECONOMY AND THIS CONGRESS
FOR THEIR OWN BENEFIT.
>> REPUBLICANS ARE FOCUSED
ON DELIVERING A WIN FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND ON A
PROMISE TO THEIR SUPPORTERS
SO THAT CAN MEAN SETTLING
FOR WHAT THE SENATE HAS
ALREADY PASSED.
BUT IT COULD ALSO BE A WIN
FOR SOME RED STATE
DEMOCRATS, PARTICULARLY IN
TRUMP STATES.
>> SOME OF THESE DEMOCRATS
ARE RISKING IRE FROM AN
ENERGIZED FAR-LEFT BASE TO
DO THE RIGHT THING IN AN
ELECTION YEAR, TO HELP
PEOPLE.
GOOD FOR THEM.
THEY DESERVE CREDIT FOR THAT
IF THEY DO THAT AND
REPUBLICANS ABSOLUTELY
SHOULD NOT LET POLITICS
STAND IN THE WAY HERE.
>> THIS IS BROKEN DOWN TO A
BIT OF A SQUABBLE.
SOME ON THE SENATE SIDE SAY
THEY ONLY WANTED TO VOTE ON
THIS ISSUE ONCE.
HOUSE LEADERSHIP SAYS IT
WANTS THE VOICES OF ITS
MEMBERS TO BE HEARD AND THEY
ARE NOT ASKING FOR
CONTROVERSIAL ITEMS.
BOTH SIDES INSIST THEY WANT
TO PUT A BILL ON THE
PRESIDENT'S DESK.